I got a hug man I love this game so much
[Music]
[Applause]
hey Marvelettes Ryan Panaji oh say ka
Agent M here outside the square and
Express conference at e3 2019 where we
just revealed Marvel's Avengers to the
world very exciting so exciting in fact
that I had to grab a couple of fans and
see what they thought let's check it out
I'm here with Bruno Amy Megan right I'm
here with my man Dave Dave Marvel's
Avengers we saw the trailer were so
reveal how you feeling I can't put it
into words man I Avengers popped on that
screen you saw San Francisco you saw the
Quinjet fly-in I just I had a religious
experience Ryan
Captain America dies right and who was
the person narrating the entire thing
you know what after watching the teaser
for about three years a hundred times
this was so satisfying man I'm stoked I
mean did you guys really killed Captain
America I'm really eager to see what's
happening with with Steve Rogers we
already got like all care just like I
got camp I got cap you know everyone's
just really excited for the game and I
caught me off guard like the gameplay
look really cool like everyone's like
looks like they play completely
differently when they mentioned that it
was gonna be 4 player online Cola we
were like yo it's time it's time count
us in and you got great voice actors
when we saw the voice actors there I was
like we've seen them all over the place
we're in I'm gonna say it game of the
year right now I'm calling it marvel
square crystal thank you you're the
champion no one else is gonna top you
this is what I want if I could have it
tomorrow would love you but May can't
come fast enough as you can see people
are hyped and so am i it's a big III
2019 for Marvel
stay tuned for so much more I'm Ryan and
this is Marvel your universe
[Music]